what is going to be your field of
mastery life and if you really want to
go to that next level then what you have
to do is you have to start to think in a
different way successful people are
extremely persistent they do not quit
when it gets tough the more you study
people who have been successful the more
you see what it really takes what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe that you have the
ability to do something special that can
change the planet so to help you on your
journey today we're going to learn from
youtuber entrepreneur and life coach Leo
gora and my take on his top ten movies
for success rule number ten is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys liked the best
perhaps the most important thing is need
to find your life purpose as soon as
possible life purpose is what is going
to be your field of mastering life how
do you want to impact the world what are
you most passionate about how do you
create a career out of your top passion
in life if you can figure that out and
become definite about it and be crystal
clear about it then that's gonna focus
all of your energy into that and you're
gonna become a master an expert in that
and from this will come a lot of your
financial success from this also will
come a lot of fulfillment and a lot of
satisfaction because fulfillment comes
from being good at something you're not
gonna be fulfilled at life by just
dabbling in a bunch of little stupid
things or working a job that you're not
really excited about you need to
position yourself as an artist in life
what's your art form you got to find
what that is if you have some nascent
passions you know some passions that are
still kind of like just starting to bud
go and nurture those and just see where
they take you if you're interested in
art go do some art if you're sidin music
go play some music if you're interested
in starting a business go maybe try
starting a business and just see where
that takes you you might discover like
oh I really love this or no you know I
thought I loved it but I actually kind
of hate it and those are very valuable
insights for you to have but as you're
exploring around always keep your eye
out for the choice you got to make a
choice you got to make a commitment and
a decision as to what your life is going
to be about what are you gonna be
mastering next is set big goals
successful people set big goals in fact
they set gargantuan goals and you have
to do that too there's a tendency to say
that we want to set realistic goals you
might say well I'm not going to set too
ambitious of a goal because there's a
risk that I'm going to fail well instead
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna focus on
a goal that's realistic that I can
attain the problem with that kind of
thinking is that a lot of
times those realistic goals that we set
are under valuing what we can actually
do in our lives right you're selling
yourself short you don't really know how
much potential you really have until you
set a very ambitious goal I'm sure at
one point in your life you have done
that and you've actually been able to
meet it or even exceed it and you felt
the power of that setting an ambitious
goal a big goal is a great way to
supercharge your motivation and
successful people are very passionate
and motivated that's because they said
big goals for themselves if you set a
weak goal a small goal a realistic goal
what's gonna happen is that you're not
gonna get engaged with it you're not
gonna get excited enough to really go
out there and take the action and
counter Tooley what might happen is that
realistic goal that you set might
actually be harder to accomplish than
the very very ambitious goal because the
ambitious goal has a heart to it whereas
your weak piddly little goal well who
really cares if you accomplish you're
not it's not gonna have a big impact on
you and so I'm gonna have a big impact
on the world so have goals out there
that are a big that are about not just
you but about other people too
your best strategy and success chances
of success in life chances that
fulfillment and chances that most the
most people liking you is to be yourself
because when you're yourself your
authentic self your magnetic you're
attractive people want to be near you
maybe not the same people that want to
be near your fake self right now so
acknowledge that I'm not saying that you
can maintain everything in your life as
it is and still be yourself you might
need to make some sacrifices there might
be some costs because she has on right
now you've horned yourself out and now
you have some social bets right and when
I tell you to stop caring about other
people and start being authentic well
you're gonna come up with all sorts of
reasons about why that's too costly for
you you're gonna say well then my boss
will say something bad my job might be
in danger my relationship I be in danger
something else might be in danger
well what's more important to you is
that more important to you for you to be
getting those shallow things or is it
more important for you to be self
expressive to really be yourself to
really be fulfilled inside and then to
act from that
and to live your life from that and to
create a business from that place to
create a career from that place to
create a nice relationship from that
place what's more important I mean you
can still keep whoring yourself out if
you want to but in the end being a [ __ ]
is not a good way to look to go through
life so my suggestion is to to bite the
bullet on this one and be yourself
despite the costs the next thing is I
would say the hard work hard work is
really really important to be successful
and to be at the top like 10% of the
population in terms of success all those
people who work their ass off you're not
going to be successful without hard work
and the reason mostly is not even they
have to go out there and and build a
giant Empire or you have to a mass
amount of money or work long hours it's
not even so much about that it's that
you need to develop yourself because
success is not so much an outer world
state as an inner world state and that
might sound kind of hokey and new-age
but it's very very true success is
grounded within you you're not going to
be able to maintain any sort of level of
success if you do not have the
psychology to really follow principles
to know how to maintain success to think
strategically to think long term to
delay gratification to resist addictions
all these factors come into play
so really for me success is grounded in
self mastery it's understanding yourself
and then building on that building
disciplines building successful habits
which then move you towards where you
want to be going there's something to
this idea that there can be no problem
that is not an opportunity in your life
and I think this is what the core of
positive thinking is is understanding
that every problem every challenge that
you have is ultimately an opportunity
and this is not just some wishful
thinking this has not said lightly this
is something that takes some study this
has takes some study and some content
to understand it takes wisdom to really
understand this you have to have some
life experience to shock to see the
truth of this the depth of it because
there's like a surface level
understanding and then how much deeper
layer of understanding that's why you
have to kind of go back and look at your
own history just try to prove it to
yourself to proof yourself of this is
true because right now I tell you this
but you probably saying yes this sounds
nice and sure it could probably work for
many problems in my life
I can see that somehow I'm
catastrophizing them exaggerating them a
lot of times they don't come true but
you know there's just this one problem
I've got right now I've got this one
problem
that's just pure hell it's pure hell
it's pure evil there's no possible way
that this problem I've got right here
there's no possible way that this could
have any opportunity in it there's no
opportunity here there's no lesson to be
learned here
there's nothing pot this is just pure
negative if I could remove it from my
life my life would be happy I would be
better I just know it well that's
exactly what I'm trying to tell you is
that that's not positive thinking and I
mean I understand where you're coming
from a lot of times I get triggered like
that too and I was especially like that
a lot in the past and I'm still a bit
like that today but you gotta understand
that this is the mode of thinking that
you've been coming from for most of your
life and that that mode of thinking has
gotten you to where you are right now in
your life so that's gotten you to where
you are but that's only gotten you to
where you are and I'm willing to bet
that you can do better than where you
are right now and if you really want to
go to that next level then what you have
to do is you have to start to think in a
different way sometimes if I start
thinking in a radically different way a
way that seems uncomfortable a way that
seems wishful thinking at first a way
that that seems unrealistic that seems
idealistic that seems fantastical yet
there is something to this idea that
nothing can happen
that is not positive I guarantee you
that if you really look at it if I
really sat down with you and we really
looked at that challenge that you have
right now that's totally unsolvable
that's ruining your life if we looked at
it we can pick out I guarantee we can
pick out something positive something
you could learn from it of course this
doesn't mean that all the sudden your
problems can be fixed it doesn't mean
that your problem is not a real problem
it doesn't mean that you shouldn't work
to fix your problem
it doesn't mean that you don't feel the
pains of your problem I'm not denying
you any of that but I am saying that
once you adopt this mindset and you
become a positive thinker then you're
gonna be able to Aikido a lot of your
problems if you don't like yourself then
ask yourself the following question do
you really not like yourself or do you
not like an aspect of yourself big
difference right is it you all of you
that you don't like or just an aspect I
bet it's just an aspect so if that's the
case first of all realize how much
you're focusing on it right and I want
you to take that camera that you have
right now and you're totally zoomed in
on this one in profession that you have
you're totally zoomed in on it I want
you to zoom out and see yourself and
your whole life and the whole history
that you've have of your life and where
you're going see all of that and put
that in perfection that one imperfection
is a context right it's still there I'm
not denying it it might not be there
maybe you have some crooked teeth or you
have a big nose or you have a fat ass or
whatever or maybe you have some you know
character flaws in you not physical
problems but character flaws and you
don't like yourself for those reasons
okay
let's admit that that's there let's say
that it's true it's there well that's
that's one aspect of a much bigger
picture so first of all realize that
that's the case and if that is the case
then also realize this point is that you
have a choice of what you focus on you
you've got this you've got this like
laser beam in your mind which is your
focus right your awareness and this
laser beam it's it's consciously guided
by you not all the time but you can
guide it
and so if you're always hating on
yourself then what you're doing is
you're taking your imperfections and
you're always like shining a magnifying
glass over it that's what's happening
you're shining this magnifying glass on
your imperfections sometimes all you do
is you just stare at them all day right
and that's why you feel so bad about
yourself supplies because you stare at
those imperfections ceaselessly well if
you've got an imperfection there's that
you only got two choices either you're
gonna fix it
either you can change it or you can't
now go out there and try to change it if
you can I mean that's what I'm all about
I'm giving you a lot of advice and stuff
with all my videos about you know how to
put your life into place may actually
make it really good objectively good but
if you can't change it maybe like your
physical appearance you can't you feel
like you can't change it or you don't
really want to go that far then that's
fine you can then learn to accept it in
the sense that you're gonna shift your
focus away you're gonna kind of accept
it and not look at it anymore stop
looking at it because it's the cost of
looking at it and then read looking in
the re looking in the re looking that is
that's really killing you you're gonna
start to focus on other areas of your
life that are great and we're gonna
realize when you make that shift is
you're gonna realize that while that
little imperfection it's fun that
important anymore
and then maybe a couple of years down
the road you will actually laugh you
will laugh because you'll laugh and say
how could I have possibly been so
concerned about that it's so
insignificant now because I've got all
this other awesome stuff flourishing in
my life
next point do not quit successful people
are extremely persistent they do not
quit when it gets tough and it will get
tough I don't care how passionate you
are about what you're doing I don't care
how much you love it whether you love it
or you don't there's gonna be ups and
downs in life and whatever you're
pursuing whatever kind of big goal you
set for yourself especially if you set
those big goals they're gonna be
challenging they're gonna require you to
grow they're gonna require you to step
outside your comfort zone and that means
emotional labor will be involved that's
okay but to to make sure that you get
through that and to get to your ultimate
objective of success you're gonna have
to have persistent and you can't quit
when the going gets tough so you know
maybe you're working on a project and
something's not working out the way you
want something slips something fails and
you're really tempted to quit and throw
in the towel or maybe there's a
relationship and you're trying to work
it out but it's not working and you're
tempted to drop it you're tempted to
quit there you know whatever part of
your life you really want to quit or
drop right now if you're in that kind of
point you gotta push through it if it's
really aligned with your values and
aligned with your purpose if it's not
aligned you can you can drop it in fact
you should but otherwise you have to be
very very persistent if you read
biographies of the most successful
people throughout human history business
leaders social leaders politicians
celebrities actors you know that just
the underlying theme of all those
biographies and all their histories is
that they were very very persistent and
they were okay with failure in fact most
of these people they were so successful
because they failed so much that they
just couldn't their success was
inevitable because after you fail
thousands of times you start to learn
your lessons and you start to get good
and the human brain is really really
really stubborn and it doesn't tend to
learn from success as much as it does
from failure so when you're failing a
lot don't get discouraged
push on persevere go through your
hardest moments because those hardest
moments that you go through that's where
you learn your biggest lessons and those
are what grow you to be able to handle
bigger and major challenges to
accomplish more and more and get that
kind of success that you want and these
are also coincidentally the proudest
moments of your life the moments of your
life that you will never ever regret so
never quit when you're doing something
that's important to you being able to
focus is critical to getting you the
results that you want focus is all about
eliminating distractions so what are the
distractions right now that are keeping
you from being focused go ahead and sit
down pause this video and jot down five
things
what are five things that are keeping
you distracted in whatever area of life
you want more focus
so are you not focused at work what is
distracting you is it hunger because
you're not eating in the morning is it
your boss who comes in and disturbs you
every 15 minutes or is it emails is it
the Twitter feed that's pinging you is
it your cellphone that's vibrating from
text that you're getting hit up with
well you know what is distracting you
what about at school what's distracting
you there what about in your
relationship was distracting you there
sit down and identify those factors
because once you've got those identified
and I think what you'll find is actually
that one of the biggest factors that
you'll find is multitasking you trying
to do multiple things at one time and
that of course is the antithesis of
focus when you're doing multiple things
you are not focused by definition you're
splitting your focus and when you split
your focus it's like you know what it's
like it's like imagine if we had the Sun
and it was a bright sunny day and I gave
you a magnifying glass and I said here
you can take this magnifying glass and
if you hold it up at the right angle and
you hold it steady then you can burn
that ant right there on the ground or
you can set that leaf on fire and at
first thought you'd say like wow that's
if you didn't know that you say wow
that's that's amazing I can't believe
that's true let me try it then you take
that magnifying glass and you would run
over and you try to burn an ant or burn
a burn a piece of leaf and but of course
if you didn't listen to the fact that I
told you that you have to keep it steady
and you have to focus the Rays that
what's gonna happen is you're gonna just
kind of move move it around move it
around move around and you're gonna come
back to me to say what the hell nothing
worked this this you're lying to me this
doesn't work it's not possible to take
the sun's rays and burn anything with
them they're they're too weak and of
course the problem is that you didn't
focus the Rays first that's exactly what
its life and you're like in your life if
you're trying to get some success in
your career and your business at school
what you need to do is you need to put
your your full attention on it right you
need to bring all those rays to a point
you need to bring your thoughts to a
point your mind has to be focused on
whatever it is that you're doing of all
the things I regret the mo
as I regret that I didn't start
meditating when I was six or seven years
old if I started that habit man I would
be at such a different place in my life
right now I'd be so much happier so much
more fulfilled meditation is the key to
mastering happiness and happiest is
different than success you could read
all the self-help books in the world and
become very successful but you still
will not be fulfilled and happy and
that's because you haven't practiced
meditation so start tomorrow 20 minutes
a day at the very least make that
commitment for the rest of your life
you're gonna meditate for 20 minutes
every day for the rest of your life no
matter what no sick days no days off
you're never gonna miss a day
starting tomorrow that's your mission
and then after a year - I recommend you
bump that up to one hour per day if you
really want to supercharge your
fulfillment levels in life and then the
last point and this is one of my
favorites and this is one that people
really miss out on is study success
successful people study success success
is not what we naively think it's just
something that happens naturally to some
people and doesn't happen to other
people success is a very deliberate
conscious endeavor that you undertake
success is built over months and years
and it's done consciously and the more
you understand the principles of success
the concepts of success the more you
study people who have been successful
the more you see what it really takes
and that process of success the
principles are not always what they seem
and to me this is something that I
really committed my life to is studying
these principles I really love it it's
exciting for me and I really encourage
you to get involved with that so that
means maybe attending some seminars
reading some books watching these videos
learning about it maybe joining a group
of friends that are successful joining a
mastermind group right be around
successful people learn how the success
process works and learn the psychology
of success not the externals of success
but the psychology that's what we're
talking about
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because 700 13 ad asked
me to if there's someone you'd like to
vote on for the next top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
have your say finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Steph Reverend thank
you so much stuff for picking up a copy
in my book your one word and for all the
support doing the unboxing video all the
posts you've been putting in social
media I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
thank you everyone and let's rock my
world word so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
so confidence let's understand why
you're not confident so where exactly
are you feeling unconfident on a date in
your work situation where are you
feeling unconfident there how exactly is
that being manifest when you're sitting
at a meeting in a group meeting and
people are standing up and voicing their
opinions and you're sitting there and
you're kind of being quiet and meek make
a note of that if that's you or maybe
it's when you see an opportunity in your
job maybe to step up and maybe put
yourself in line for a promotion
position and your mind tells you no no
no don't don't do that stay safe stay in
your current place and maybe you're
lacking confidence in that way right or
maybe you're lacking confidence in
voicing your thoughts and you can't get
those out or you're finding that you're
having to hold back your thoughts so
make a list of all these different ways
that you are not being confident then
what I want you to do is I want you to
analyze each one of those situations
that you're facing and say what is an
alternative set of actions that you
could be taking so what would a
confident person be doing so let's say
in that on that date situation what
would the most confident person who's
extremely confident with the opposite
sex
what would he or she do how would he or
she think and jot down some specific
points how would he talk about his
stories how would she be thinking about
the situation how would he or she be
carrying him someone with the body
language be like what would the thought
process be same thing with the situation
at work or anywhere else make a list of
alternative actions that you could be
taking that would feel confident to you
if you took them so that is going to be
kind of your game plan once you identify
the situations and you identify the
alternative actions you kind of know
what you need to do basically what you
need is you need to start changing your
behaviors and you need to start now
living in and practicing those
alternative actions you have to have a
deep understanding of who you really are
in life to have long-term sustainable
success and both happiness and then
fulfillment right and for me success is
shallow if it does
come with happiness and fulfillment
component so for me I want to get all of
it both the external success and then
the fulfillment the lasting fulfillment
and happiness that you can get with that
I don't want just shallow external
success and to do that you need to
really understand and discover who you
are and you might be thinking well I
Know Who I am no you don't most people
out there I would say 99% of people do
not really know who they are because
they have not gone on the journey that
it takes to discover that and what I'm
really talking about here this is not
some abstract notion is you really need
to discover what your top 10 values are
you need to discover what your top 5
feelings are in life you need to
discover what it is that you really want
out of life what it's meaningful to you
and you got to also discover what you
don't want and you might say well I know
what I don't want I know the things I
don't like well there might not be as
much clarity there as you think it there
is so this is all about a matter of
clarity and articulation it's one thing
to know begley it's a totally different
thing to actually articulate it write it
down and know it very very consciously
it's gonna clear a lot of things up for
you and you're gonna sit down and do
this process
you're gonna quickly realize that you
don't know as much about yourself as you
think you do and you probably have had
moments in your life that have been like
epiphanies where you had deep self
discovery maybe it was when you were
traveling maybe it was after a breakup
in a relationship maybe it was when you
were struggling at work you discover
things about yourself and by going
through these these challenging
experiences we really discover what it
is that we want out of life and that's
the foundation successful people know
what they want I want you to read one
self-help book every single month it's
not a lot just one per month that's not
a lot you can handle that most self-help
books are pretty short so all you need
to do is just have a list in fact I have
a list of some of my favorite most
powerful self-help books on my website
and go check that out actualize that org
but this is this is a huge habit here's
why because self-help books have
basically distilled all the principles
of success and happiness that human
beings have discovered in the
last 2000 years and especially the last
hundred years there's been so much
research done on how to be successful in
business how to be successful in
relationships how to be successful with
your happiness levels how to meditate
properly the scientific benefits of
meditation and so on and so forth and
self-help books are not just abstract
you know very pedantic type of books
that you might read in college these are
very practical these are written to get
you results these self-help books have
exercises in them they have techniques
read those start practicing those if you
just read one book per month for the
next let's say eight years that would be
close to a hundred books that would give
you the entire theoretical foundation
that you need to master life